46,74 % des voix Jean Germain se trouve
dans une position plus que confortable à
l'issue de ce premier tour un taux de
participation supérieure de près de 4%
par rapport à 2001 et un vote parfois
sanction à l'encontre de l'UMP une
équation qui n'a certes pas fait gagner
le maire sortant dès le premier tour
mais qui le place à 19 points d'écart de
Renault Donio de Vabre écoutez une
réaction plutôt
oui de de satisfaction puisqu'on
améliore notre score de 2001 de plus de
plus de 6% le candidat de de l'UMP et de
des autres forces de droites finalement
un peu patiné donc
de ce point de vue là c'est correct
ensuite sur le sur la ville elle-même
pour les municipales il y a 20% de
différence avec Renault Deneuve vape
donc je pense que c'est c'est un écart
quand même conséquent un écart
conséquent que l'on mesurait hier soir
avec gravité ou que j'ai de campagne du
candidat UMP 28% des voix pour rdv soit
8 points de moins qu'en 2001 déjà battus
aux dernières législatives l'ancien
ministre affirme pourtant que la
campagne peut maintenant débuter en
insistant sur l'enjeu local de ces
élections municipales j'allais dire à
mon électorat vous avez un peu pensé
nationale maintenant penser local
pensez à tous les sujets qui sont sur la
table est-ce que vous voulez oui ou non
du tramway à 600 millions d'euros est-ce
que vous voulez un maire qui va gérer
pépère de façon perfide avec des accords
de sous-sol honteux ou est-ce que vous
voulez quelqu'un et une équipe qui est
remplie d'énergie pour mener à bien un
certain nombre de grands projets pour
notre ville que les tours en jours
regardent concrètement pour l'avenir qui
sera le meilleur au-delà des étiquettes
politiques avenue Grammont on avait
également du mal à garder le sourire le
candidat divers droit de Guillaume
Pelletier n'a pas gagné son pari du
maintien au second tour un peu plus de
8% des tours en jeu ce sont exprimés en
sa faveur une défaite pour Guillaume
Pelletier qui évoque son entreprise
d'ouverture politique lors de sa
campagne et qui dans le même temps
affirme ne pas vouloir jouer contre son
camp au second tour